The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So today we're going
to do an example of
using some of the equilibrium
concepts that we've learned to
drug design.
And it's going to be an example
that's out in the
literature.
And potentially a very big
deal if you can do
drug design this way.
And it's an example of how,
remember how I told you that
if you have the Gibbs free
energy, you have everything
and how clueless I was as a
graduate student, and when I
look back I think how silly it
was for me not to realize how
important it was.
Well, this is an example where
people calculate delta G's or
Gibbs free energy changes for
binding of proteins to
receptors on cells,
or ligands.
And from that, design drugs that
work much better than the
real thing.
And it's all about calculating
delta G. We're going to see
how that is, and how that comes
in with equilibrium.
So the paper that this
is based on was
published in 2002.
And since then there have
been larger-scale
trials, animal trials.
And I believe there have been
human trials of this concept,
of this drug that they
have designed.
You've got the reference
in the notes.
And we're going to have to do
a little bit of review of
biology first, to figure
out what's going on.
And this particular process,
this particular drug, is
called the, I have
it right here,
granulocyte stimulating factor.
Where was it in here?
To give you the right
name for it.
There it is.
It's a protein drug
called GCSF.
Granulocyte Colony Stimulating
Factor.
And it's there's wild
tie for natural
version of this protein.
That is generated by
normal tissue.
And this protein goes to the
blood, to the bone marrow.
And it binds the receptors on
cells that are in the blood
and the bone marrow, and
stimulates the growth of white
blood cells, and stem cells, and
also acts to tell the bone
marrow to pump out these stem
cells into the blood.
And the problem is that if you
have a chemotherapy patient,
their bone marrow cells are
largely destroyed through the
chemotherapy.
And so they have a problem
with the white blood cell
counts, and with stem cell
counts and all that stuff.
So one of the ways that you
can try to reverse this
problem is by stimulating,
artificially stimulating the
growth or the proliferation of
these white blood cells.
And one of the ways you could
do that is by giving the
patient a lot of this protein,
granulocyte colony stimulating
factor, to stimulate the output
of white blood cells
from the bone marrow.
Whatever is left of
the bone marrow.
To rebuild it up.
And so that's done with wild
type, with protein.
You can make the wild
type protein.
But if you had something that
was basically the same thing
but somehow mutated, where you
made a few changes to the
amino acid sequence, so that it
worked a little bit better,
then you might have a lot of
people, a lot of patients.
And that's what the basis
of this paper is, that's
referenced here.
Is how to go about mutating this
protein here to make it a
drug that would be
more effective
then the natural protein.
So that you can give
it to patients.
So now let me go back and tell
you a little bit about this
equilibrium that we're
talking about.
So we've been talking
about equilibria of
molecules coming together.
And then creating
new molecules,
products and reactants.
Well, when you're talking about
ligands and receptors on
cells, the same sort
of ideas come in.
The same equilibrium
concepts come in.
So if you have a cell membrane,
the cell membrane
could have a receptor in it.
Which is a protein that extends
through the membrane
that's got some sort of
pocket outside here.
The membrane keeps on going.
And you've got the blood on the
outside here, or some of
the tissue of the cells,
and you've got the
inside of the cell here.
And this receptor is waiting
for some ligand.
A ligand being another protein
that's floating around.
That's specific for binding
to this receptor here.
And there's the ligand here.
There's the receptor here.
And every now and then one of
these ligands will find a
receptor and bind to it.
So we write, then, in
equilibrium, ligand plus
receptor goes to complex.
This is happening all
the time on cells.
There are millions of different
kinds of receptors,
millions, billions of
kinds of ligands.
Wild types, fake ones,
et cetera et cetera.
When you've got a binding event,
the cell knows that's
something has bound, usually.
And that usually triggers a
cascade of other things.
It signals a cell to
do a lot of things.
So, for instance, in the case
of the GCSF, you've got the
receptor on the cell.
And you've got this granulocyte
colony signaling
factor, that would be
the ligand here.
It binds to the receptor
on the cell.
That triggers the bone marrow
cells to produce more
proteins, which signals more
things to happen, and
eventually down the way, after
a bunch of signaling
processes, out come a
burst of stem cells
or white blood cells.
It's a complicated process,
and every step of the way
needs to be done correctly.
And for this process at least,
this protein here, this ligand
protein, triggers the cascade.
And so this binding and
unbinding of this protein then
triggers the whole sequence
of reactions.
So this equilibrium becomes
super-important then.
OK.
What else should we review
about, I should have used a
different board than
this, but.
This is going to
get covered up.
What else can we review about
biology that would be
interesting?
So, other things that we will
need to remember, need to
know, is that these receptors
on the surface of the cells
aren't static.
The cells recycle
their receptors.
Things can happen.
Things get degraded.
And so the cell is constantly
taking these receptors,
bringing them back inside the
cell, merging them with
lysosomes, where the pH is five,
or 5.5 compared to the
outside of the blood,
which is 7.4.
It breaks down the proteins into
their amino acids, the
cell can use the amino acids
again to make more proteins.
Make better, make
new receptors.
And that's how the cell recycles
the receptors.
So basically, you end up with
the cell taking the receptor.
Making a small sort of cavity
around the receptor.
So there's the cell
sitting here.
There's the inside
of the cell.
There's the receptor being
engulfed by the cell, now.
And it could have the ligand
in on it, also.
There's the ligand sitting
right here.
It's called an endocytotic
event, or it's endocytosis of
the receptor.
Into the cell.
And then once you're inside
the cell, let's put the
nucleus in the middle here,
you've got things called
lysosomes that are
sitting nearby.
There's a lysosome here.
Lysosome.
And there's your little
vesicle that
contains your receptor.
Merges towards the lysosome,
these two get together.
Then you have your ligand, I'm
running out of colors here.
So there's the receptor and the
ligand together in here.
And then the pH here becomes
5.5, things break apart.
And you've got to find another
receptor, another ligand, to
continue the process.
Everybody knows this biology,
or you know it well enough.
OK, good.
So let's go do this example.
So this is the process
of binding.
We can have a delta G associated
with this, delta G
a, delta G0 is minus
RT log K sub a.
This is the association
equilibrium.
And you can have the reverse
process, where the complex
gets broken up into receptor
plus a ligand.
And then you have a delta
G for this process here.
So this is delta Ga,
let's call it.
This would be delta GD, which is
the negative minus RT log K
sub D. This is the dissociation
process.
And the dissociation process,
K sub D, is equal to R, the
concentration of the receptors
times the concentration of the
ligand, divided by the
concentration of the complex.
And the lower K sub D is, the
smaller this number is, small
means that you're mostly on this
side here, mostly in the
complex, the tighter
the binding.
So small KD means
tight binding.
So if I want, in principle,
then, if I want to design a
drug that's going to signal this
event here, I want K sub
D for this ligand that
I'm going to
design to be very small.
To be small.
Small enough so that it binds
strongly and does its job, so
I don't need too much of it.
Now, you need to do experiments
to figure out
what's going on.
So how do you do these
experiments?
You need to be able to measure,
then these K sub D's,
experimentally, to see whether
or not what you've designed on
the computer, when you calculate
delta G's on the
computer you've got to know
whether or not it's working.
And this is still an
experimental science.
How does it work?
So, usually you do the
experiment with the ligand
concentration very high.
Very large.
So that the concentration of
the ligand at any time is
basically the same thing as
the concentration of the
ligand you put in.
So you overwhelm the system
with ligands.
So that L is much bigger than
C or R, and so it doesn't
matter which way the
equilibrium is.
L stays roughly the same.
So you know, throughout
the experiment, what
concentration is.
Then you get a bunch of cells.
In a well or something, or a 96
well plate with a bunch of
different kinds of ligands.
And you can take your ligand,
you can label it
radioactively.
So you can take your ligand
as some long protein.
And you can take an iodine 125,
let's say, radioactive
label on your ligand,
on your protein.
So you can keep track of it.
The nice thing about radioactive
labels, and which
is why people use them in
biology or bio-medicine.
We use them to look at, for
instance, bio-distribution of
things in animals.
We want to know where things
are, and whether they all left
the animal, or.
Because you can use a Geiger
counter and you
can count the events.
The radioactive events.
And that gives you extremely
quantitative analysis of where
things are.
So you take those radioactive
ligand.
And, L0, very large
concentration.
You expose this concentration
to the cells.
The cells have some receptors
on the surface.
There's a bunch of receptors
on the surface of the cell.
And some fraction of the
receptors will have the ligand
bound to them.
So you incubate.
You let it wait a while.
Then you wash.
So you get rid of all
the excess ligand
that's on top there.
And then you take your petri
dish, or your 96 well plate.
And you read the radioactivity
that's coming from the cells.
And that signal, that
radioactive signals, tells you
exactly how many ligand you
have on these cells.
You knew what the cell
concentration was initially.
So that tells you what the
concentration of ligands, of
complexes, was.
So this experiment then gets
you, experimentally, gets you
the concentration of
C, the complex.
So now this is something
you know.
You also know what L0
was, because that's
what you put in.
And that's enough for you
to find out what KD is.
And if you know what KD
is, then you know
what delta G0 is.
And so generally, then, let's
go ahead and do that.
So we know what L is.
We know what L0, C is, let me
just do it on this board here.
So we start with rewriting KD as
equal to R times L divided
by the complex concentration.
And now L is basically L0, so we
can use that approximation.
So we have L0 sitting here.
We still have the complex on
the bottom, and that's
something that we've
experimentally discovered.
And the concentration of
receptors, this is the
concentration of receptors
that don't have
anything bound to them.
So it's these guys right here.
That's equal to the
concentration of receptors,
the total number of receptors,
minus those receptors that
have a ligand bound to them.
Complexes.
Something we can
experimentally define, or discover.
So we replace this R here with
RT minus C. And then we're all
at equilibrium.
So we're going to put a little
equilibrium sign under these
C's here. equilibrium.
And then we can rearrange this
equation so that, people like
to have plots that are linear,
in a way that is a linear
plot, where the slope of the
plot is the inverse of the
equilibrium constant.
So you do some massaging
of this equation here.
And you rewrite it in
terms of C over L0.
There's the equilibrium
concentration of the complex.
This is the total receptor
concentration divided by the
equilibrium constant.
And then you have the
equilibrium concentration of
the complex divided by KD.
And so you plot, then,
this ratio.
Which is an experimental
ratio.
You've just measured this
concentration of complexes
using this radioactivity,
radioactive labeling
experiment.
You know what this is, because
that's what you've put in.
This is your x-axis
on your plot.
This is what you've measured.
And this is going
to be the slope.
It's called a Scatchard plot.
After Mr. Scatchard
So you get a straight line.
So we're plotting here
the equilibrium
constant of the complex.
And on this here we're plotting
the ratio of the
complex divided by L0.
And we get this straight line
like this, where the slope is
one over KD.
Minus one over KD.
OK, now there's a couple of
things that you can look at
that are sometimes useful.
In this analysis here.
You can also rewrite this
equation up here in terms of
the ratio of C equilibrium
divided by RT.
So that's basically the ratio
of receptors that have a
ligand attached to them,
divided by the total
concentration of receptors.
So if most of the receptors
are empty, then this is a
small number.
Then most of the receptors are
taken up, this is a number
close to one.
It can't be anywhere, it can't
be ever bigger than one,
because the biggest number of
complexes you can get is the
total number of receptors.
So if you take this equation
here and you massage it a
little bit, one over one plus KD
over L0, and that, you can
also plot that.
As a function of L0.
How much ligands you put in.
And you find this is something
that saturates at one.
So this ratio here is going
to saturate at one.
This is C equilibrium divided by
total number of receptors.
And so if L0 is small enough, if
L0 is small enough, meaning
that it's smaller than KD, so if
L0 is much smaller then KD,
then you can rearrange this
ratio here so that C
equilibrium divided by RT
is roughly L0 over KD.
So that's linear, with a
slope of one over KD.
So this slope here is one
over KD is the slope.
And as you get L0 to be quite
large, bigger than KD, then
this saturate to one.
And this one over something very
large become zero, and
basically you end up with
something close to one.
So you saturate at one.
So that's another way
of doing this.
But this is really what we
want to concentrate here.
The fact that you can get KD
out of experimentally.
If you have KD, you
have delta G.
So now let's go back and think
about this whole process here.
If we're going to design this
drug here, this protein,
artificially.
So what you want, then, is you
want something that's going to
bind strongly enough to
receptor, to stimulate the
growth of granulocytes, or the
colony of granulocytes.
But when the cell decides to
recycle the receptor, and
destroy it, chew it apart in
the lysosome here, you want
this drug not to be degraded.
Because you have to keep
injecting in the patient.
So you want this drug to release
from the receptor,
before the lysosome has a
chance to chew it up.
So that means that you want the
equilibrium constant at pH
5.5, you want that KD, to be
much larger at 5.5 than you
want it at 7.4.
You want strong binding at
pH 7.4, and you want weak
binding at pH 5.5.
That way the drug
gets recycled.
Can find, go back
to the blood.
Bind to a receptor again,
generate the signaling events,
gets engulfed by the cell.
Releases before it has
a chance to be
chewed up, et cetera.
The wild type will
get chewed up.
The regular kind will get chewed
up, and so that's why
you have to, with the patients
you have to keep giving them
this drug over and over again.
Because it gets chewed
up by the cells.
So that's the design principle
that these authors had in mind
when they started their study.
And so they knew what the
sequence, what the amino acid
sequence was, for this wild type
drug, and they started
doing point mutations.
Changing one amino acid
here and there.
And cranking out the calculation
to calculate delta
G for binding of this protein
to this receptor.
At pH 7.4 and at pH
5.5, and getting
differences of delta G's.
So let me then review again.
What is the motivation here.
The motivation is to try to
get the ratio, KD, at 5.5
divided by KD at 7.4, pH 7.4.
And you want this to
be bigger than one.
And really as large
as possible.
As possible, of course
within limits.
So we want this to
bind at pH 7.4.
And the point of comparison
is the wild types.
Which at 7.4 has a KD
of 270, roughly.
And at the ratio of pH
5.5 to 7.4 is 1.7.
So it's a little bit weaker
binding at 5.5.
Remember, large KD means
weak binding.
Small KD means tight binding.
So the fact that KD at 5.5 is
bigger than KD at 7.5 means
that it's slightly weaker
binding at 5.5 than 7.4.
So this is sort of the baseline
that the protein
designers had to deal with.
So everything gets compared
to this guy here.
So they don't actually, in
a calculation they don't
actually measure this.
What they do is, they
look at delta G's.
And so they look at differences
of delta G's.
They look at delta G0 for
the binding of the
ligand to the receptor.
At 7.4 minus the delta G0 at
pH 5.5, let's call this the
delta delta G. Since you know
delta G is minus RT log K,
this is equal to minus the delta
of log KD, which is log
KD at 5.5 divided
by KD at 7.4.
So then they calculate delta
delta G0, and it's completely
related to this ratio that you
measured in the experiment.
And so for the wild type, this
delta delta G is just
basically the log of
this number here.
Is 0.53.
So now they go ahead and
do their calculation.
And they find a couple
of mutants.
Where, and they focus
on delta delta G0.
They want something that's
bigger than this.
And then they'll worry about
whether there are more
problems associated with it.
So they found two mutants,
let's call
them D110H and D113H.
I think it's a histidine
mutation, point mutation at
110 and 113, where this ratio
here was 8.3 and 17.
So, huge differences here.
More than a factor of 20, or
factor of 30 difference in the
change in the binding
efficiency, at least according
to these delta delta G, between
pH 5.5 and pH 7.4.
That means that this protein
here with the point mutation,
with this one point mutation, if
it binds as strongly to the
receptor on the surface, as soon
as the lysosome comes in
and begins to decrease pH inside
the cell, this ligand
is going to come off.
And it's going to be
able to float away.
Hopefully, before it
gets recycled.
Before it gets chewed up.
So they can be used again.
So that's good.
Alright, so experiments
were done.
And on the D110H
and the D113H.
And KD was measured in
the experiments.
And remember, the wild
type is 270.
The KD's were at 370.
And 320, with some error bar.
And the different, the ratios
of KD's were measured.
There were 4.4 and 6.8.
With some error bars.
And they turned out to match
reasonably well, at least as
far as comparison between
experiment and theory.
Still not great for these sorts
of calculations, because
pretty involved.
A lot of approximations
go on in there.
And it gives you
a rough guide.
So this 17 here is probably not
quite right, because it
doesn't quite translate
to 6.8 here.
This difference between 4.4 and
6.8 doesn't quite match
the difference that they saw
here in the calculation.
But it's the right
direction, right?
And that's why you still
need to do experiments.
This number here is a
little bit bigger
than this number here.
Which means that these don't
bind quite as strongly.
Because KD small means
strong binding.
That means the initial binding
of the ligand to the receptor
is not quite as good
as the wild type.
That's often the case.
It's often not so easy to find
something that binds as
strongly as the wild version.
But, it's good enough.
And this ratio is really
what clamps the deal
in this case here.
And so, these mutants, in fact
these two mutants are the ones
that have undergone
the animal trials.
That are in the pipeline.
This is a big deal.
This is a big deal because this
is a huge, huge market.
There's a very large number of
people that are affected with
chemotherapy.
And this is basic thermodynamics
here.
It's basic thermodynamic
calculation of a complicated
molecule with some fairly simple
equilibrium concepts.
OK, any questions on this?
OK, well, we're ended
really early today.
I don't have the phase
transition ready, but Keith
Nelson is going to start a phase
transition next time.